todo esto forma parte de una
investigación judicial que se abrió el
pasado 7 de julio aquí en francia por
parte del tribunal de justicia de la
república este es el tribunal la
instancia que está habilitada para
investigar a los miembros del gobierno
se abrió el 7 de julio en realidad desde
el comienzo de la pandemia se recibieron
cerca de 90 demandas pero solamente
nueve de ellas fueron encontradas
procedentes y todas éstas forman parte
digamos de todo un paquete de estas
demandas que en realidad quieren saber
si los miembros del gobierno estaban al
tanto de medidas sanitarias que debían a
tomar para luchar contra la pandemia y
que en realidad no lo hicieron en caso
de que se pruebe esto pues esto es
considerado un delito penal aquí en
francia y pues esto pueden llevar a
penas de hasta dos años de cárcel y
treinta mil euros de multa así que eso
es lo que están realizando la
investigación que está realizando las
autoridades actualmente